rick doblin how are you my friend well
rested and super excited to be here with
you today well I I gotta say I'm
thrilled to be here with you I am I
really admire you and I salute you for
the work that you're doing in the world
to bring relief to so many that are
suffering to alleviate human suffering I
mean if there's ever been a solid reason
to get out of bed in the morning it is
to serve our fellow our fellow man to
help others
yeah I've been fortunate in the sense
that I've been driven by this the fear
of what people can do to each other when
they're irrational elements takeover
interested in this the fear of the
Holocaust the fear of dehumanizing
others and that's what led me to really
focus on psychedelics but I've had such
a loving family and such support that
the fear has been not overwhelming but a
powerful powerful motivating force well
that's the interesting thing about fear
right that fear can drive us to such
madness and such cruelty but it can also
in the right interpretive framework yeah
fear can actually fuel our desire
capacity and willingness to extend our
hands towards one another to bring
others into awareness really you know
there's a great quote I once came across
and it said that empathy rarely extends
beyond our line of sight right and
empathy rarely extends beyond our line
of sight and that actually makes a lot
of sense because then you know what is
out of sight is out of mind so the
question becomes then how do we well how
do we extend our line of sight how do we
expand our compassion well we do it
through insight interesting tell me more
well the insight that we're connected to
everything that we're connected to the
Amazon burning
that were connected to refugees from
Syria finding nowhere to take them in
that we're connected through this
insight through this common humanity
common life on this planet so that our
site then can extend and we can be
compassionate for the whole planet so a
change in consciousness beyond the
broadcasts of the ego to the broadcasts
of the whole yes what is needed which
reminds me of that South African saying
Ubuntu I am because you are hmm which is
beautiful and it's funny just this
morning I was reading an article in a on
magazine that was drawing an analogy
between astronauts when they go into
orbit and and and that cognitive shift
that occurs when they see the planet as
a whole thing the overview effect yeah
and they were saying that that is
analogous to the experience that many
people are having now with psychedelic
psychotherapy yeah and all of a sudden
they're starting to see this kind of
bigger picture perspective and
identifying with something larger than
themselves and how that has all of these
immense benefits to mental health yeah
and I think what often people get
confused about is that when you have
this larger consciousness it doesn't
mean that you lose sight of who you are
in your individual life so we talk about
ego death and I don't think it's really
ego death it's more ego moves into the
background from being in the foreground
mm-hmm and so you're part of a larger
world but you don't disappear and I
think that's really reassuring to people
to realize that you can be this
consciousness of the entire history of
the universe but you still have a role
between life and death that you don't
disappear and the other aspect of this
is my youngest daughter Ellie one of her
closest friends in school her
grandfather was Michael Collins who was
on the Apollo when Neil Armstrong yeah
and walked on the earth and walk down
the moon Wow and so what Michael said to
her was so beautiful was that after they
traveled around the world after they
came back from the moon and they
traveled for different countries the
feeling was not that we Americans had
done that had done this but we humans
had done this and that was again that
ego shifting from us being in the
foreground to us being in the background
as part of this bigger picture that's
really well put because I think some of
the reservations that some people have
about having an experience of ego death
is not so much the cognitive benefits
that might ensue that sounds amazing but
it's the idea that you have to die in
order to experience that radical
interconnection and and there is terror
about submitting completely to your own
dissolution of self you know but you
know you once used an analogy when
comparing maybe like LSD and MDMA you
told me that you know where's LSD my
smash your lenses of perception
something like MDMA in that it's a
little more gentler a little more gentle
little more empathic genic actually just
kind of clean cleans the windshield of
your lenses of perception but doesn't
completely shatter them yeah what I'd
like to say is that you know MDMA is
like the diamond polisher uh-huh LSD is
like the diamond cutter interesting oh
that's right and also that there's
another way to think about it that LSD
moves you if we want to say the Sun you
know moves you towards the larger
universe dissolves the ego in certain
ways and moves you to the larger
Universal you can see a bigger picture
but MDMA grounds you so comfortably in
the earth that then you can see the
bigger picture you're not trapped in
your subjectivity well that's that's
very beautiful and and you know this
gets us obviously to the subject at hand
and the subject of your work you know I
am I'm very interested in in in
consciousness and I have always been
driven by by the question right there's
a great line I forget
I think it's Walker Percy who said it he
said this search is what anyone would
under
if they were not sunk in the
everydayness of their own lives to
become aware of the possibility of the
search is to be on to something well and
not to beyond to something is to be in
despair and so this this this search
this existential agitation has always
driven me like what are we to do in the
face of our mortality what are we to do
in the face of our finitude what are we
to do with ourselves and when you keep
reading about on the one hand are
astounding technological progress you
know the planet cloaked in connectivity
human beings transcending time and
distance with wireless communication
technologies that dazzle you flew across
across the country yesterday on a
machine with a million moving parts so
we are more connected than ever before
and yet subjectively there is this kind
of consistent report appealing to people
feeling disconnected and alienated from
one another and and the United Nations
put out a number recently said more
people are committing suicide now then
are dying from natural disasters and
armed conflict combined so yeah yeah
that armed conflict and natural
disasters are killing less people but
WTF that we're killing ourselves in
suicide like well in America last year
more Americans died of drug overdoses
hmm then died then Americans died in the
entire Vietnam Afghanistan and Iraq Wars
so in one year more Americans died of
drug overdoses and Americans died in
those three wars we should make a
distinction between what drugs were
talking about here not from psychedelics
not at all from second okay not at all
and I think dogs can be the solution for
some people who are trapped in addiction
but I'd also like to say that Albert
Einstein had a quote that I resonate
with a lot which was that our technology
has exceeded our humanity hmm so we are
wrapped in this incredible technology
hmm and what we've been able to do over
let's say the last five hundred years or
so is sort of by putting science over
religion mm-hmm science has been
able to with our rational mind make
enormous progress but we're in many ways
an insane species destroying the world
destroying the environment destroying
each other building more weapons of mass
destruction and we don't have the
humanity we don't have the emotional
capacity the spirituality to deal with
the technology and so that's what in
1972 at age 18 led me to realize that
how do we help expand our humanity and
for me that turned out to be
psychedelics yeah
then the more I studied that I realized
that we've been we as humans have been
using that for thousands of years and
that rather than continue to develop my
mind what I really needed to do is get
more in balance and so that's where I
dropped out of college for ten years
yeah well that's very interesting I mean
even this phrase that our technology has
exceeded our humanity I think speaks to
the fact that what is urgently needed is
is on a cultural scale a shift in
consciousness and a shift in our
existential orientation and our North
Star the story that we tell ourselves
about ourselves the current one is no
longer convincing to many and where as
maybe traditional religion is not the
answer people still need a North Star
they need an orientation right they need
a poetic truth that it's beyond the
literal grid beyond the reality that we
are born and that we die like why are we
here and why does it matter and so ya
talk about tapping into heart and
intuition and empathy and compassion for
our fellow man what is truly needed is a
change in consciousness and you talk
about psychedelics as playing a crucial
role in this well what our ultimate ly
psychedelics well they are also
technologies but they are different
sorts of technologies they are ecstatic
technologies they are technologies of
inner space right stanislav grof
famously said about LSD but I think you
could draw that conclusion about other
psychedelics they could do for
psychiatry what the telescope did for
astronomy and so this is exciting
this is an exciting time to be alive
exactly and if you look at what
struggles people had who early on used
the telescope hmm with Galileo and what
would happened they would they would
look at the through the telescope and
have a bad trip no they would see things
that the society wasn't ready for
hmm it wasn't so much that they had a
bad trip it that they had a good trip
and they saw things that were ahead of
their time it couldn't integrate it and
what one of as long as we're talking
about quotes well my my favorite quote
which speaks a lot to courage and
holding to that truth is that one of the
people that was early on accepting the
Copernican revolution and the
information that galileo got from the
telescope was a Roman Catholic priest
called father Bruno and because he
challenged the current worldview at the
time that the earth was the center of
the universe he was condemned to die and
to be burned at the stake by the
Inquisition and what he said after he
was sentenced into the judges there from
the Inquisition he said your fear in
condemning me is greater than my fear
and being condemned that they were so
scared of what it would mean for them to
have to reorient their structures and
that they couldn't go through yeah that
ego death they were so trapped in who
they thought they were and what they
thought the universe was and that they
were at the center of things and they
had all the power they couldn't you see
beyond that so they were terrified of
the truth more than he was terrified of
being burned at the stake and and
actually there's a psychological theory
that accounts for that that actually
built on the work of Ernest Becker so
Ernest Becker wrote the 1974 politia
prize-winning book the denial of death
which placed death anxiety as the sort
of worm at the core of human neuroses
right kind of displacing the idea of the
Freudian idea that we're just sexually
repressed and that's why we're neurotic
yeah
but it's actually because we are
repressing the fundamental disquiet of
knowing that we are mortal like that
every day we get out of bed and we have
the leave we trivialize our lives with
trivialities but in the grand face of it
everyone you know and everyone you love
is gonna be taken away from you and
you're gonna die to disappear forever
like what the [ __ ] and from that these
these psychologists develop something
called terror
management theory and terror management
theory basically says that if you remind
somebody of their mortality for the most
part essentially my understanding is
that two things can happen but what
tends to happen a lot of the time is
that they become more aggressive and
unkind towards others now some people
you remind them of their mortality they
become more compassionate but the idea
behind this theory is what they sort of
derived from that is that when you have
a cultural worldview right that you
cling for dear life - right because this
cultural house of cards is your
existential blanket right I am an
American or I am Venezuelan or I am
Catholic and Jesus loves me or whatever
whatever it the thing that you're
clinging to for meaning right is any
other or alternative interpretation or
cultural worldview that is presented to
you in your face right is actually
perceived as a physical attack on your
person and so people respond to it as if
you were trying to kill them and that
explains for example this example of the
of the telescope is that yeah this was a
machine right an instrument that was
threatening to so fundamentally shift
our ontology right that on the one hand
wow it could have like been an overview
effect for the planet but the powers
that be were like this is an existential
threat to our hierarchical power
structure and our interpretive
frameworks we have to burn this person
at the stake you know and so that's a
really interesting insight into how
strongly we cling or can cling to our
belief system yeah and I would say that
the the the main challenge that we face
now as a species and also as political
activists is to help people move away
from fundamentalism from literalism
mm-hm
into mysticism and this idea for me was
really confirmed by Robert Mueller who
was the assistant secretary-general of
the United Nations and in 1983 he wrote
a book called New Genesis shaping a
global spirituality and again global
spirituality doesn't mean that
individual religions disappear we have
one world religion it just means that we
see that religions are like language
they're all attempts to communicate the
same kind of things and one language is
different than the other but it doesn't
mean French is better than German or
German is better than English and if we
can help people surrender that Grif
grasp on the literal and move into the
poetic the symbolic that's what we need
to do that's our challenge is to and in
this increasing globalization world
cultures are no longer isolated from
each other where they have to confront
the fact that other interpretative
frameworks and other people have said
this is the way to spirituality or this
is our priest or this is our founder or
Buddha Muhammad you know Jesus Moses
whatever one's that there has to be this
way where we can appreciate differences
and celebrate them rather than be
terrified by them yeah you know when I
when I spoke to Eric Davis who wrote
tech gnosis he brought up the work of
Bruno Latour I believe who talked about
different modes of being and I think
that making sense with these different
or making peace with the different modes
of being you know finding a way for
contradictions to be reconciled or
embracing the kind of paradox Akala t
when you can hold multiple truths in
mind at once is the way we get there you
know one example being again art and
science right or the poetic and the
literal you know for example mythology
and archetype vital to our to our well
being storytelling human beings are
storytelling animals we think in
metaphors and archetypes it's how we
make sense of ourselves it's how we
contextualize our lives right but what
is a myth a myth is false from the
outside but true from the inside right
right or Eric Davis says these kinds of
experience can be taken you know
experiences of the mythic and the
transcendent must be taken seriously but
they don't have to be taken literally
that's how the poetic avoids turning
into militant scripture that's how you
avoid creating a new religion and
becoming a self-righteous mouthpiece for
everyone else but it doesn't mean that
you have to let go of your own personal
poetic truth Alain de Botton the British
philosopher has a very similar line and
this is something that just resonates
with me infinitely he says yes look a
journalist or a scientist or a literal
minded person might be more accurate in
describing the details of an event than
a poet but a poet may nevertheless
reveal truths of a deeper sort that are
beyond the literal grid very much so
that's it right there
Ursula Le Guin science describes
accurately from the outside poetry
describes accurately from the inside
science explicate s-- poetry implicates
well even Albert Einstein said that
there's really no conflict between true
science and true religion there's
conflict between false science and false
religion but there's no conflict between
what we understand in terms of values
and spirituality and what we understand
through science that there are literal
views that may not be upheld by science
but those are not the deepest views
something you said earlier really
resonated with me about how we
trivialize our lives yeah but also how
we end up helping people to look at a
deeper truth and so it reminded me of
the need hierarchies of Abraham Maslow I
love Abraham Maslow's hierarchy of needs
yes yeah and how I think what is
enabling Trump to succeed so well I mean
not that he in his own terms is that
he's playing on people's fears and
anxieties because their basic survival
needs are being challenged you know with
technological change oh yeah
you know robotics and all sorts of ways
in which people's jobs and how they get
income and how they survive or being
challenged so as long as people are at
that level of survival needs that's
right they're they find it hard to see
the bigger picture yeah and so that's
where we need to find a way to in a
compassionate world to share the
resources not have them all accumulate
with a few people at the top and that
then people will have that sense of
security that they can move from that as
a base yeah towards looking at their
fears and their anxieties and how people
might be different from them their
prejudices well but we need to have that
basic sense of security I agree
I think that populist in general they
either intuitively or Machiavellian in a
Machiavellian fashion they exploit
people's existential fears about their
basic needs not being met I mean the
whole Maslow hierarchy of needs is like
well look if you have to eat nothing
else matters but once you've been fed
then maybe you kind of want a roof over
your head and once you've got a roof
over your head well maybe you want like
a sense of esteem and belonging and then
once you've got that you're like you
want to make some well and once you got
that you're like what's it all about
[Music]
people also aren't aware of a transition
that Maslow made in the last few years
of his life towards peak experience well
beyond that so the well anyway yes then
so that ppm Maslow's need hierarchy for
most people still in many textbooks yeah
the top of that is self-actualization
that you become your full self that you
know and that is in some ways like the
libertarian ideal you know that we all
have this ability to actualize ourselves
and and that once you've got your
security needs taken care of and your
belonging needs then then you can kind
of you know full flower into your nature
but because of peak experiences because
of psychedelic experiences in the last
few years of his life
Abram Maslow who previously had helped
start humanistic psychology which does
have this idea of positive psychology
self actualization he also with Stan
Grof and a few others started
transpersonal psychology and so the
beyond self beyond self so self
transcendence is actually at the top of
Maslow's hierarchy so after
self-actualization after transcendence
yes and so it's service to others it's
you become part of this larger thing
it's not just about yourself anymore
it's not just about your own full
actualization it's about transcending
the self and helping everybody get to
that place you know what it feels like
mother nature has our back on this
you've probably heard of the helpers hi
right
the helpers hi says that on a
neurochemical level we get reward
we got like pleasure chemistry
circulating in our brains when we help
other people yeah so it's like there's
this
kind of drew there's an incentive
there's a reward pathway here to extend
our hands towards one another and I
think what is what is realized what is
what is required is people just to
realize this to come around to see that
by helping others helping themselves to
yeah mirror neurons to of how we can
really respond to other people yeah so
let's get into this you know you started
Maps right the multidisciplinary
Association for psychedelic studies you
had an ontological shift when you had a
psychedelic experience you're like if
everybody was able to have an experience
similar to this you know we could mend
our suffering heal our brokenness and
move towards the next step in our
evolution and you had remarkable
progress in in in kind of putting a suit
and tie yeah around the seriousness of a
psychedelic experience and putting away
the tie-dye shirts and finding ways to
integrate this and going through the
proper channels to bring this into
mainstream acceptance you know you know
actually it's so interesting you use
that metaphor of the suit-and-tie
because for so many of our events and
speeches I wear a suit and tie yeah and
lately on a few occasions I've no longer
been doing that and for me that's a sign
of progress that was a symbol sure that
I'm willing to bring the psychedelics
into mainstream society and work within
and grow from within yeah and I feel
that we've accomplished a lot so that
that symbolic participation in the
mainstream doesn't need to be so literal
anymore although I'm gonna be giving a
talk tomorrow where I'm going to be
wearing a suit and tie to a group of
people who are what's called the
institutional review board the Western
IRB review our studies and other studies
yeah and they've invited me just to give
you a historical sense how incredible it
is so in 2003 we got permission for the
first study with MDMA for post-traumatic
stress disorder and the permission was
from the FDA and then we had to get
permission from the institutional review
board
which colleges universities hospitals
they all have these institutional review
boards they were created after the
Nuremberg trials after the Nazi
experiments on unwilling volunteers who
were not really volunteers and many of
them killed in these experiments so the
institutional review boards were created
for human rights for scientific research
and so this Western IRB approved our
study and then a month later we got a
letter from them saying we've revoked
the approval and we believe we've called
independently a certain number of people
and they say that MDMA is terribly
dangerous and you've misled us and one
dose could be permanent brain damage and
it's a terrible thing and we're no
longer gonna support this study and so
we ended up in about a six month
negotiations with them where we got
experts from all different scientific
fields to write letters to them and then
at the end of this they said it's not
really about the science it's about the
politics we want to have nothing to do
with MDMA here's your money back which
they never do and just go away and the
problem is that once you get rejected by
one IRB then the next IRB you have to
tell them what happened with the first
IRB and so that sort of brings this
stigma forward and Fordham eventually we
went through seven IR B's all of them
either refused to work with us or looked
at it for a while and then said we're
just never going to approve it so then
maps as an institution I said all right
we're gonna start our own RB we can do
that I read all the regulations we
started our own RB and then I said okay
well I'm relaxed we can do this research
but before we go ahead I'm gonna try one
more time because it's not so great -
from an optics to approve your own
studies even though it would be an
independent group of IRB so I read the
list of private IRB s there were about
28 of them and one of them was called
Copernicus IRB and I thought if any IRB
is willing to acknowledge the scientific
suppression from religion and politics
it would be Copernicus IRB and as it
turned out they were willing to work
with us it took a long time but so in
2004 we are finally able to start the
first study for MDMA for Pete
we've been working with Copernicus IRB
this whole time and several years ago to
my utter shock and surprise
Copernicus IRB was bought by the Western
IRB funny the one that rejected us at
the very beginning and but things have
changed so much so now I've been invited
by the Western IRB to give a talk to
their staff to their training to the
people that they work with and so well
it feels strange from the inside out I
mean and you feel it I mean I haven't
opened my Facebook feed once the last
six months or my twitter feed where
there hasn't been some glowing article
about psychedelic psychotherapy right
and you know it's amazing whether it's
the Johns Hopkins stuff happening with
psilocybin for end-of-life anxiety the
MDMA stuff that Maps has been doing
around PTSD I mean you just see like
every week there's another study using
psychedelics to help alleviate some form
of mental distress and then Robin
Carhartt Harris in the Imperial College
of London and his team they came up with
this kind of theory that it encompasses
all mental illnesses or I'll call it the
entropic brain and they talk about like
your sense of self or the default mode
network in the brain becoming like over
rigid and over vigilant you know for
whatever reason whatever your trauma was
whatever it is that sidelined you at
some point in your life that left a scar
that made your ego move into the realm
of becoming a tyrant and then that's
characterized by obsessive thinking
intrusive thoughts and rumination which
again affects anxiety this plays out in
depression plays out in anorexia plays
out in all these illnesses seem to share
this signature of rigidity in the brain
and then they'd hold metaphor is that
these psychedelics are these ecstatic
technologies can kind of have a shaking
the snowglobe like affect which can
bring this increased clarity that when
you're stuck behind your own lenses
hyper rigid lenses of perception you
can't see right because you see with
your lenses and you see through your
lenses but only when you have a
psychedelic experience do you become
aware that you have lenses yeah so it
seems to happen you bump up a level and
now you see your own lenses and you can
be like oh this is not serving me so
then you can dispense with the lenses
and what's interesting about that
interpretation is that it allows us not
to contend
with the poetic aspect of the contents
of people's experiences when you take
MDMA or LSD or psilocybin and you feel
that you commune with the cosmos and/or
have a divination of the great beyond
and that's the experience the mystical
experience that cures you in a
measurable quantifiable way we don't
have to get into the literal truth of
that experience that can stay in the
realm of poetic truth it's like
separating church and state all we care
about is that we can quantifiably
measure increased trait openness
increased engagement with the world no
longer meeting the criteria for these
pathologies that's the only thing that
we need to show as science the contents
of the experience those are for you
church and state separate yeah yeah it
doesn't make sense although I'd like to
refine this a tiny bit in the sense then
some people have said MDMA is not a real
psychedelic that it doesn't dissolve the
ego in the same sense yeah so I think
there's two fundamental therapeutic
mechanisms operating here okay one is
you talked about the default mode
Network which basically means that's our
sense of self in the brain our ego sense
and that's scanning the world according
to our Maslow need hierarchies so we
filter all the information that comes in
about what are our needs and that's
being done through this default mode
network and when you weaken the default
mode Network you see the broader world
again the self moves from foreground the
ego moves from foreground to background
the self the larger self moves from
background to foreground and then that's
tremendously healing for people and with
the work with LSD with psilocybin both
from the 50s and 60s and the recent work
there's a correlation between the depth
of the mystical experience and
therapeutic outcomes
now MDMA is different so so in addition
to that spiritual sense you talked about
the filters that we see life through and
a lot of those filters are based on
traumas on different things that have
happened to us in the past that are
coloring our sense of is it a safe world
is it a dangerous world and so that's
where MDMA comes in MDMA can help us
with these filters that are stories from
the past
that aren't not necessarily relevant to
the actual future interactions and that
the essence of PTSD is that you see
everything through these filters and you
can be out in public you can be safe you
can hear a noise and it reminds you of a
bullet you know so what we've found with
MDMA therapy is that people are able to
approach fearful emotions in a much more
open way to process the fear that was
overwhelming before and we've studied we
use the same measure of mystical
experience that's used in the work with
LSD and psilocybin and we do not find a
correlation between the mystical
experience and therapeutic outcomes from
PTSD so basically the traumas and the
filters have come from what's happened
to us during our biography and that you
need to be centered in your ego in your
biography and remembering your exact
memories from childhood from other
incidents that have happened to you and
approaching them in a different way and
also MDMA reduces activity in the
amygdala where we process fear it
increases activity in the prefrontal
cortex where we think logically but very
importantly it increases connectivity
between the hippocampus and the amygdala
which is where we process memories into
long-term storage and so there's been
kind of like a clogged drain you could
say these traumatic memories are stuck
and they seem like they're always about
to be happening and with MDMA you can
and and other therapies can do this to
us not just unique to MDMA but that you
can take these previously terrifying
memories and then look at them more
dispassionately place them in the past
they're part of your journey but they're
not your entire story and you can put
them in long-term memory and you have a
sense of peacefulness about it and so
then that the what's called fear
extinction and memory reconsolidation so
fear extinction is you no longer are
triggered by those things and memory
reconsolidation means that we used to
think that memory was like taking a book
off the shelf and then you read it then
you stick it back but it turns out that
memory is taking a book off the shelf
you read it you remember it but then you
have to reprint the book
and you put it back and that's how
memories get changed over time according
to our you know that's how you can
change fastest and that's how you change
your past and so what we're essentially
doing with MDMA is bringing memories
from the past that are traumatic we find
that people's memories for trauma is
increased under MDMA so it actually has
a memory enhancing effect and these
memories are tagged with terrifying
emotions but when you look at them from
a peaceful perspective you put them in
the past when you reconsolidate the
memories you've swapped out the
emotional content to the episodic memory
so people's episodic memory is enhanced
and you've swapped out the emotional
tone to it and that's the memory
reconsolidation and so then in the
future when you remember that thing
again
you've got the memory but you don't have
the terror in the fear you know where
the emotional association is now severed
yes and so I think that's why there is
no direct connection between the
mystical experience with MDMA for PTSD
and how change actually happens in that
way that's very interesting it's almost
like with MDMA
you're first and foremost gonna have to
deal with your stuff and and that has to
happen before you can let go enough to
maybe deploy the other psychedelics
which can facilitate something that is
beyond your own personal biography and
more it helped I think in the future
when we have thousands and thousands of
psychedelic clinics all over American
all over the world I think a lot of
times people will start with MDMA that's
right and they will move through
cleaning their filters sure and and
learning how to let go and learning
things that are terrifying can be
processed and then we'll move to more of
the classic psychedelics like LSD or
psilocybin or ayahuasca or ibogaine
there was a OD mescaline interesting you
say that there's a British philosopher
called David Pierce he wrote this
treatise called the hedonistic
imperative where he challenges us to
deploy bio technologies and ecstatic
technologies to radically transform
subjectivity and and develop gradients
of bliss for ourselves beyond measure
and he has a whole section
on MDMA pharmacology and and whatnot he
spends a lot of time writing about it
and there's one section that struck me
is that he said that MDMA was a glimpse
of the perfect human state yeah but then
he went on to say that classic
psychedelics while potentially can be
quite useful and and transformative for
people but that he nonetheless stopped
short of saying everyone should do them
because the risks of a bad trip were too
great but he didn't say that from the MA
he said MDMA everyone should try and
it's interesting because you know in my
in my own experimentation I I've I've
always been a fan of cannabis and me too
and you know I think we had a
conversation about like cannabis can
take you as far as LSD if you let it and
I find it to be very psychoactive and
very resonant with set and setting and
all the same frameworks and and planning
that go into a classic psychedelic trip
I think have to be deployed for cannabis
so that you have a good trip and when I
was but I but I've been curing being
curious about other classic psychedelics
um I was like mmm not sure but MDMA yes
because I recognized in in a lot of my
own story a lot of the things related to
trauma anxiety hyper vigilance a
temperament that brings the past fear to
the doorstep of every moment that really
spoke to me and and I read a book by a
guy called David lensing his comparative
literature professor he wrote a book
about the phenomenology of altered
states it's called on drugs and there
was one session where he was getting
into this idea that consciousness is a
collaboration between subject and object
and so really consciousness is is like
an equation it's it's person x place x
time which reveals again a Garden of
forking paths of possible experiences
that you can have and then he wrote he
went into a section where he talked
about like anxiety or like bad trips or
trauma and he described anxiety and I
thought this was great he described it
as temporal dislocation hmm right so
when we talk about a past experience
that was so impactful in a negative way
right that we don't fully digest it we
now bring that past experience
to the doorstep of every moment it
becomes the filters into which we
approach life like I this scary thing
happened to me and it like solidified
into these lenses of fear now everywhere
I look I'm looking for that passive
sensation right and your brain you know
we got to love our brains it's trying to
protect us that trauma is because our
brain is like well I'm not gonna take
any chances on that happening again so
he says the past trauma is now over
determining the present exactly
misperceiving what's happening now clout
you're not saying what it is you know
you seeing what you are you see the
world so you're over determining the
present and then from this because the
brain is a prediction machine from this
misrepresenting or miss reading of the
present you're now projecting a future
right that becomes identified with death
doom despair whatever it is and so I
thought this was fascinating because it
made me just it made me crystallize a
complex subject I was like oh it's just
temporal dislocation so I have to
freaking go back to those things perhaps
through the rose-colored lenses of an
MDMA experience and change my
relationship with the past right and
then you can see more possibilities in
the present and you're not colored by
that but I would add one cautionary note
sure to this idea that everybody should
take MDMA okay well then in controlled
environments with guides all right well
a lot of people do benefit from taking
MDMA in celebratory context without
guides and all my dance parties or
festivals of all over the world which I
think can be incredibly healing so I
think we've pathologized
recreation you know so when you hear
about recreational drugs that somehow
hedonistic and destructive and reckless
and MDMA is the most inherently
therapeutic of all the psychedelics and
a lot about that I like well a lot of
people the the essence of our
therapeutic approach is that we help
people to heal themselves yeah we're not
like the magic surgeon going into your
brain and doing the work that we're
creating us
safe place for you to heal yourself and
you have to face the fears you have to
process the emotions and so to give an
example I think that if people are
willing to face whatever happens
whatever emotions come up then MDMA
could be tremendously helpful but but
this is years ago about ten years ago we
were contacted by in one week two women
contacted us both of them said
essentially the same thing that they had
had recreational experiences at parties
they taken MDMA and they had remembered
prior sexual abuse and sexual assault
one of them told the story about how
they were with a bunch of friends and
the friends didn't want to talk about it
they only wanted to be party they wanted
to be light-hearted and so this woman
stuffed her feelings down and then
months later she still felt worse
mmm-hmm the other woman told the
different story she was with a
girlfriend they went off into the corner
of the party she talked about what
happened she processed it and then an
hour later she's able to go back to the
party right so I think that it's it's
the essence also of what our approaches
is mdma-assisted psychotherapy
it's the psychotherapy it's the context
the approach that really makes the the
drug experience the drug is a catalyst
but how you approach it is really
important so it is that that's the
qualification that people if they were
to take it they need to do it in a way
where they're open to whatever emerges
they have enough support if possible for
that opens but I do believe so maps is
basically a non-profit pharmaceutical
company trying to develop psychedelics
and cannabis into prescription medicines
and we're we're different than most
pharmaceutical companies there's many
different ways but one way is we think
people should have access to these drugs
without having to go through their
doctors or through some religious
freedom arguments that these drugs
should be available in a system called
licensed legalization like you have to
get a driver's license to drive a car
you should have a license to do drugs
and this license is basically easy to
get and if you misbehave you get
punished for your misbehavior and then
you lose your license to buy the drugs
for a period of
time soldier the classic example is
drunk drivers so there's a lot of drunk
drivers who end up losing their drivers
license they still buy alcohol though
and they kill people even without their
drivers license so because we know now
about Commerce and credit cards an
instantaneous evaluation of you got it
enough balance left in your credit cards
that we should have a license like that
to buy drugs and so I think that we
should be moving to a post prohibition
world the other limitation of medicine
of medicalizing psychedelics is it's
only for diagnoseable diseases and so
for example couples therapy is one of
the very best uses of MDMA
but we've even had discussions with some
of the FDA consultants that we have and
there's no way to make MDMA into a
medicine for a couples therapy because
it's not a disease you can't make
psychedelics you can prescribe somebody
xanax for anxiety and well anxiety yes
anxiety is a disorder and you have to do
research to show so that it helps with
anxiety but but couple being married
because a tremendous amount of anxiety
coexisting with another human with their
[ __ ] and your [ __ ] coexisting can cause
tremendous meetings I I mean couldn't we
reframe the whole thing and be like hey
by the way being alive and sentient yeah
can make you very susceptible to micro
PTSD contemplating mortality can make
you susceptible to pts well and also
this insight that we talked about about
the connection with the rest of the
world yes you know I mean reading the
newspaper generates PTSD wars here
whereas their missiles they're what's
going on with the environment what's
going on with species exactly you know I
just read the other day about how there
used to be just enormous numbers of
salmon that would spawn every year and
now people are predicting in 20 years
the salmon might be gone and the media
if it bleeds it leads to begin with
because it's wired for our amygdala and
we're wired to pay more attention to
that which is dangerous which further
even warps the interpretation of the
information which is like again we're
wired for danger is what kept us alive
in the past so yeah I mean I just feel
that you on that basis alone you could
argue that to be a lie
and sentient makes you susceptible to
PTSD and thus you should have access to
the yes and there's another aspect of it
which is fundamental human rights so as
we talk about the Constitution of
America and we've got the freedom of the
press the freedom of assembly the
freedom of speech the freedom of
religion and underlying all of them is
the freedom of thought inside our own
brains when we're deep in contemplation
the freedom to think certain ideas or to
explore certain states of consciousness
is fundamental and so the prohibition
against drugs is a prohibition against
fundamental human rights to freedom of
thought and so but how do we get there
so we get there by focusing on pain on
where the society is hurting we're
they're willing to accept something new
because maybe that will help them out of
the pain that they're suffering yeah and
where the pain is the most acute is
where you're less likely to face
resistance when you're making your case
for using these medicines you know and
some of the work together quickly with
with MDMA you worked with you know
people who have suffered horrific trauma
Army veterans people have been to war
and who have seen things that they can't
unsee necessarily and the traditional
treatments aren't working right and
you've had what is the success rate
within the well well one year after the
last MDMA experience 2/3 2/3 no longer
at PTSD and this is severe chronic
treatment resistant PTSD so it's
remarkable and of the one-third that
still have PTSD a lot of them have had
clinically significant reductions in
their symptoms and on the basis of that
we're now in Phase three the final stage
of research to make a drug into a
medicine over the history of maps since
1986 we just added up astonishingly
we've raised over 75 million dollars in
donations all charitable money phase
three is going to cost us around thirty
four million dollars we've now enrolled
sixty of what we hope will be 200 in
order to make this drug into a medicine
we're also trying to move
to Europe and we need to raise another 8
million or so for Europe we've raised
already 2 million we have a training for
therapists in the first week of October
coming up we have 8 people coming from
China therapists and psychiatrists so
from China where we've got people all
over the world that are really
interested we just had a discussion with
people in New Zealand in England who are
interested in MDMA so we are now
focusing on a painful point of the
culture which is this trauma but it's
it's interesting and strategic I'll just
point out that the first thing that you
started talking about was the veterans
so what we needed from a strategic point
of view is a patient population that's
appreciated by the culture so the sad
part is that there are way more women
that have suffered sexual abuse and rape
that have PTSD from that than war
related PTSD and yet you're getting more
attention because of the veterans
because that's such a big thing in our
society so we had to be very strategic
about what we're doing and so I like to
say that we do we don't really do
science we do political science we had
to do a lot of strategy about which
psychedelic we would start with and then
which patient population we would work
with and it had to be a patient
population that people appreciated for
which there were the traditional drugs
didn't work left a lot of people it was
obvious to the field to psychiatrists to
psychologists and to the culture yeah
and we've got roughly 20 veterans a day
committing suicide that's horrific and
it's interesting you know just to wrap
things up about what I think makes MDMA
such a incredible medicine for the
treatment of PTSD with psychotherapy is
you once mentioned with the optimal
arousal zone yes yes the analogy is kind
of like planet Earth it just happens to
be in the right Goldilocks
spot just close enough from the Sun not
too far not even close just perfect for
life to emerge it just somehow works and
what's uncanny about MDMA is exactly
this thing it's like well it dampens
activity in the amygdala where our fear
and trauma is it might just cloud the
therapy to begin with boosts prefrontal
cortex activity stimulates because it's
sort of an
derivative but then makes you feel like
relaxed and at ease and those four
quadrants you know that's an optimal
arousal zone for psychotherapy it puts
you in the sweet spot yeah for the kind
of spontaneous self healing to emerge
body intelligence exactly so if you're a
hyper vigilant if you're over aroused I
am ever vigilant everything triggers you
yes and then anything yeah and it's hard
to do therapy when you're hyper aroused
when szura on the other hand most
pharmaceutical medicines for PTSD make
you under aroused they dampen everything
benzos they they're sort of they cut off
the highs but they cut off the lows and
and you're kind of but it's hard to do
therapy when you're sedated muted and
sedated so the MDMA brings people into
this optimal arousal zone where people
are able to process trauma they're able
to feel their emotions but they're not
overwhelmed by their emotions and in a
safe supportive way I should add that
the way we've designed our studies was
to optimize therapeutic outcomes and so
what it turns out like a lot of us are
traumatized by different things but some
people some small fraction actually
develop chronic PTSD and those people
tended to have a sequence of traumas
earlier in their life not always some
people are just traumatized by something
in their adult life but most people have
who have chronic severe
treatment-resistant PTSD have had
childhood traumas as well so our
therapeutic process is as a male/female
Co therapy team and we could be more
modern and say male identified or female
identified or they could be you know
non-binary and all that but the idea is
that that you've got this supportive
structure that many people under MDMA
they talk about these childhood traumas
and they didn't have support they didn't
have proper attachment they so to have a
well-functioning kind of male/female
team to help you sort of sometimes even
experience things that you didn't have a
chance when you were young that kind of
loving support so we have a two-person
therapy team from an economic point of
view of what we're wanting to do is one
is going to be a licensed therapist the
other be a student and that's how we
train the next generation of therapists
and also reduce the cost but we think
the two-person team
works terrific yeah and so much of
trauma has to do with not feeling safe
yeah and so it feels like you know the
substance like MDMA may be
psychologically making a neurochemical
level feel really safe and at ease but
then the therapists and the environment
for psychotherapy brings the external
contexts of feeling safe and at ease and
when you combine interior space ease and
exterior space ease man now you have a
powerful combination for
transformational cognitive reframing and
healing exactly and when we described
before about how MDMA is the most
inherently therapeutic of all the
psychedelics yeah it's also the easiest
to integrate mmm whatever happens
because your ego is not dissolved you
can sort of take the lessons from MDMA
into your daily life and and even
occasionally I've had moments where I
felt like I'm on MDMA when I've not been
on empty in the same you know we've you
can learn from it yeah and that's the
beauty of it and so I think that's
what's really important also we talked
earlier on about stan grof you talked
about his ghost buddy when psychedelics
were criminalized he developed an
approach called holotropic breathwork
it's hyperventilation to bring out these
same experiences and I think the key
lesson from that is that when you have
these experiences like that it's not a
breathwork experience it's not an LSD
experience it's a human experience that
these are capabilities that we have
within us and the goal of maps I would
say is to make it so people don't need
psychedelics so that they have learned
these lessons and we can do this more or
less on our own on the other hand I do
think that there's a really interesting
study that was just done with lifelong
meditators in the Zen tradition and Zen
has been sort of more in the modern age
traditionally anti psychedelic
anti-drugs anti intoxication but as it
turns out this was a study that was done
in Switzerland Vanya Palmer's who was
the leader of the Zen tradition in
Switzerland had to leave his position
because he wanted to start experimenting
with psychedelics and to be the leader
of a tradition that was somewhat anti
psychedelic it didn't quite work so he
left this position and then this study
he wanted to do too
many many years for him to do it but a
bunch of lifelong Zen meditators went to
the University of Zurich with Franz bone
writer's team and they got brain scans
then they went into a five-day
meditation retreat in Switzerland and in
the middle of it they got a pill and it
was either psilocybin or inactive
placebo or niacin I can't remember quite
which but they got a placebo and then at
the end of this meditation retreat they
went back and got brain scans and then
they had long-term follow-ups and what
they found is that even in the Zen
tradition that one experience of
psilocybin helped them deepen their
meditation practice that you still you
think you're super open but you're still
channeled in certain ways and the
psychedelics bring things to the surface
that you might not anticipate so while
we do want to help it so people don't
need psychedelics maybe you know
throughout the lifespan every once in a
while we should be doing psychedelics
just to see what we're suppressing or
not seeing yeah and you know you could
also argue you know Michael Pollan talks
about the bin there isn't seen that of
the adult mind that essentially allow us
to run our lives on autopilot yes these
words are the good news is you're seldom
surprised right now I think of her
sidelines but the bad news is you're
seldom surprised and so these kinds of
experiences potentially could evoke a
kind of in his words the sense of first
sight unencumbered by knowingness you
know to get to look at ourselves with a
virginal noticing to get to look at our
lives with a virginal noticing to notice
the sublime miracle that it is to be
alive you know f scott Fitzgerald wrote
about these transitory enchanted moments
in which man must have held his breath
compelled into aesthetic contemplations
face to face with something can measure
it to our capacity for wonder and it is
there that we heal and we all deserve
access to these domains
I just want to salute you and ending for
the work you do to alleviate human
suffering and eventually to make well
people better exactly and I think that
the the 50 years since the psychedelic
first came onto the
scene in a major way in the 60s and was
identified with the counterculture yeah
that we have grown as a culture as a
global culture over these last 50 years
and so I do believe that we have a
really good opportunity to integrate
psychedelics into the culture and I
think one of the mistakes of the 60s was
that these drugs are the province of the
rebels in the counterculture what we're
trying to do now is mainstream them and
to make it so that these are the
province of everyone and I feel that the
world is hungry for this kind of new
globalization we know that technology's
expanding at an enormous rate we're
talking about sending you know ships
potentially to Mars we're expanding into
the cosmos and the cultures are bumping
up against each other the environmental
destruction is almost too late but
hopefully not too late and so there's
this hunger that we're trying to address
towards a different way and I think that
through the healing of trauma and the
creation of spiritual sense of
connection and mysticism that we can
help people surrender and let go of
their literal fundamentalisms and move
to a deeper spirituality amen brother
thank you so much Rick magnificent I'm
so glad to live in the 21st century
where I could fly from ocean to ocean
just to be with you and then get on the
airplane in a few hours
I am honored and humbled to grace your
presence and wish you a great next leg
of your journey and I'm sure I'll see
you soon last time we hung out this long
we were in Oslo together that's right at
the Human Rights Foundation which is
really important it's fundamental
appreciation for human rights and the
courage of those people that are willing
to stand up for it and also the trauma
that they experienced and how we need to
helped heal our human rights activists
Thank You Flo kana
[Laughter]
[Music]
you